The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
ROBERT GALLAGER: OK.
Today, I want to review
a little bit of
what we did last time.
I think with all the details,
some of you sort of lost the
main pattern of what
was going on.
So let me try to talk about
the main pattern.
I don't want to talk about
the details anymore.
I think, for the most part in
this course, the best way to
understand the details of proofs
is to read the notes
where you can read them at your
own rate, unless there's
something wrong in the notes.
I will typically avoid
that from now on.
The main story that we want to
go through, first is the idea
of what convergence with
probability 1 means.
This is a very peculiar
concept.
And I have to keep going through
it, have to keep
talking about it with different
notation so that you
can see it coming any
way you look at it.
So what the theorem is-- and
it's a very useful theorem--
it says let Y n be a set of
random variables, which
satisfy the condition that the
sum of the expectations of the
absolute value of each
random variable
is less than infinity.
First thing I want to point
out is what that means,
because it's not entirely clear
what is the means to
start with.
When you talk about a limit
from n to infinity, from n
equals 1 to infinity, what it
remains is this sum here
really means the limit
as m goes to
infinity of a finite sum.
Anytime you talk about a limit
of a set of numbers, that's
exactly what you mean by it.
So if we're saying that this
quantity is less than
infinity, it says two things.
It says that these finite
sums are lesson
infinity for all a m.
And it also says that these
finite sums go to a limit.
And the fact that these finite
sums are going to a limit as m
gets big says what's a more
intuitive thing, which is that
the limit as m goes
to infinity.
And here, instead of going from
1 thing m, I'm going from
m plus 1 to infinity, and it
doesn't make any difference
whether I go from m plus 1 to
infinity or m to infinity.
And what has to happen for this
limit to exist is the
difference between this and
this, which is this,
has to go to 0.
So that what we're really saying
here is that the tail
sum has to go to 0 here.
Now, this is a much stronger
requirement than just saying
that the expected value of the
magnitudes of these random
variables has to go to 0.
If, for example, the expected
value of y sub n is 1/n, then
1/n, the limit of that as n
goes to infinity, is 0.
So this is satisfied.
But when you sum one/n here,
you don't get 0.
And in fact, you get infinity.
Yes, you get infinity.
So this requires
more than this.
This limit here, the requirement
that that equals
0, implies that the sequence y
sub n actually converges to 0
in probability, rather than
with probability 1.
And the first problem in the
homework for this coming week
is to actually show that.
And when you show it, I hope
you find out that it is
absolutely trivial to show it.
It takes two lines to show
it, and that's really
all you need here.
The stronger requirement here,
let's us say something about
the entire sample path.
You see, this requirement really
is focusing on each
individual value of
n, but it's not
focusing on the sequences.
This stronger quantity here is
really focusing on these
entire sample paths.
OK.
So let's go on and review what
the strong law of large
numbers says.
And another note about the
theorem on convergence, how
useful that theorem is depends
on how you choose these random
variable, Y1, Y2,
and so forth.
When we were proving the strong
law of large numbers in
class last time, and in the
notes, we started off by
assuming that the mean
of x is equal to 0.
In fact, we'll see that that's
just for convenience.
It's not something that has
anything to do with anything.
It's just to get rid of a
lot of extra numbers.
So we assume this.
We also assume that the expected
value of x to the
fourth was less than infinity.
In other words, we assume that
this random variable that we
were adding, these IID
random variables,
had a fourth moment.
Now, an awful lot of
random variables
have a fourth moment.
The real strong law of large
numbers, all that assumes is
that the expected value
of the magnitude of x
is less than infinity.
So it has a much weaker
set of conditions.
Most of the problems you run
into, doesn't make any
difference whether you assume
this or you make the stronger
assumption that the mean
is equal to 0.
When you start applying this
theorem, it doesn't make any
difference at all, because
there's no way you can tell,
in a physical situation, whether
it is reasonable to
assume that the fourth moment
is finite and the
first moment isn't.
Because that question has to
do only with the very far
tails of the distribution.
I can take any distribution x
and I can truncate it at 10 to
the google.
And if I truncate it at 10 to
the google, it has a finite
fourth moment.
If I don't truncate
it, it might not
have a fourth moment.
There's no way you can tell
from looking at physical
situations.
So this question here is
primarily a question of
modeling and what you're going
to do with the models.
It's not something
which is crucial.
But anyway, after we did that,
what we said was when we
assume that this is less than
infinity, we can look at s sub
n, which is x1, up to x n all
IID We then took this sum
here, took to the fourth moment
of it, and we looked at
all the cross terms and
what could happen.
And we found that the only cross
terms that worked that
were non-0 was where either
these quantities were paired
together, x1 x1, x2, x2, or
where they were all the same.
And then when we looked at that,
we very quickly realized
that the expected value of s n
to the fourth was proportional
to n squared.
It was upper banded the by three
times n squared times
the fourth moment of x.
So when we look at s n to the
fourth divided by n to the
fourth, that quantity, summed
over n, goes as 1 over n
squared, which has a
finite sum over n.
And therefore, the probability
of the limit as n approaches
infinity of s n to the fourth
over n fourth equals 0.
The probability of the
sample path, the
sample paths converge.
The probability of that is equal
to 1, which says all
sample paths converge
with probability 1.
So this is enough, not quite
enough to prove the strong law
of large numbers.
Because what we're interested
in is not s n to the fourth
over n fourth.
We're interested in
s sub n over n.
So we have to go one
step further.
This is why it's tricky to
figure out what random
variables you want to use when
you're trying to go from this
theorem about convergence with
probability 1 to the strong
law, or the strong law for
renewals, or any other kind of
strong law doing
anything else.
It's a fairly tricky matter to
choose what random variables
you want to talk about there.
But here, it doesn't make any
difference, as we've said.
If you let s n of omega over
n be a sub n to the 1/4.
In other words, what I'm doing
now is I'm focusing on just
one sample path.
If I focus on one sample path,
omega, and then each one of
these terms has some value, a
sub n, and then s sub n of
omega over n is going to be
equal to a sub n to the 1/4
power, the 1/4 power of this
quantity over here.
Now, the question is if the
limit of these numbers--
And now remember, now we're
talking about a single sample
path, but all of these sample
paths behave the same way.
So if this limit here for one
sample path is equal to 0,
then the limit of a sub n to
the 1/4 is also equal to 0.
Why is that true?
That's just a result about
the real number system.
It's a result about convergence
of real numbers.
If you take a bunch of real
numbers, which are getting
very, very small, and you take
the fourth root of those
numbers, which are getting very
small, the fourth root is
a lot bigger than the
number itself.
But nonetheless, the fourth
root is being driven to 0
also, or at least the absolute
value of the fourth root is
being driven to 0 also.
You can see this intuitively
without
even proving any theorems.
Except, it is a standard result,
just talking about the
real number system.
OK.
So what that says is the
probability that the limit of
s sub n over n equals 0.
This is now is talking
about sample paths
for each sample path.
This limit s n over n either
exists or it doesn't exist.
If it does exist, it's either
equal to 0 or equal to
something else.
It says that the probability
that it exists and that it's
equal to 0 is equal to 1.
OK.
Now, remember last time we
talked about something a
little bit funny.
We talked about the
Bernoulli process.
And we talked about the
Bernoulli process using one
value of p for the probability
that x is equal to 1.
And what we found is that the
probability of the sample path
where s sub n over n approach to
p, the probability of that
set was equal to 1.
If we change the probability
that x is equal to 1 to some
other value, that is still a
perfectly well-defined event.
The event that a sample path,
that sub n over n for a sample
path approaches p.
But that sample path, that
event, becomes 0 as soon as
you change p to some
other value.
So what we're talking
about here is really
a probability measure.
We're not using any kind of
measure theory here, but you
really have to be careful about
the fact that you're not
talking about the number of
sequences for which this limit
is equal to 0.
You're really talking about
the probability of it.
And you can't think of it in
terms of number of sequences.
What's the most probable
sequence for a Bernoulli
process where p is,
say, 0.317?
Who knows what the
most probable
sequence of length n is?
What?
There is none?
Yes, there is.
It's all 0's, yes.
The all 0's sequence is more
likely than anything else.
So why don't these sequences
converge to 0?
I'm In this case, these
sequences actually converge to
0.317, if that's
the value of p.
So what's going on?
What's going on is a trade-off
between the number of
sequences and the probability
of those sequences.
You look at a particular value
of n, there's only one
sequence which is all 0's.
It's much more likely than any
of the other sequences.
There's an enormous number of
sequences where the relative
frequency of them is
close to 0.317.
They're very improbable, but
because of the very large
number of them, those are the
ones that turn out to have all
the probability here.
So that's what's going
on in this strong
law of large numbers.
You have all of these effects
playing off against each
other, and it's kind of
phenomenal that you wind up
with an extraordinarily strong
theorem like this.
When you call this the strong
law of large numbers, it, in
fact, is an incredibly strong
theorem, which is not at all
intuitively obvious.
It's very, very far from
If you think it's intuitively
obvious, and you haven't
studied it for a very long time,
go back and think about
it again, because there's
something wrong in the way
you're thinking about it.
Because this is an absolutely
incredible theorem.
OK.
So I want to be a little more
general now and talk about
sequences converging to
a constant alpha with
probability 1.
If the probability of the set of
omega such as the limit as
n goes to infinity
is z n of omega.
In other words, we will look
look at a sample path for a
given omega.
Let's look at the probability
that that's equal to alpha
rather than equal to 0.
That's the case of the
Bernoulli process.
Bernoulli process with
probability p, if you're
looking at s n of omega as s n
of omega over n, then this
converges to alpha.
You're looking at s n to the
fourth over n to the fourth,
it converges to p to
the fourth power.
And all those are equal to 1.
Now, note that z n converges to
alpha if, and only if, z n
minus alpha converges to 0.
In other words, we're talking
about something that's
relatively trivial here.
It's not very important.
Any time I have a sequence
of random variables that
converges to some non-0
quantity, p, or alpha, or
whatever, I can also talk
about z n minus alpha.
And that's another sequence
of random variables.
And if this converges to alpha,
this converges to 0.
So all I was doing when I was
talking about this convergence
theorem of everything converging
to 0, what I was
doing was really taking these
random variables and looking
at their variation around the
mean, at their fluctuation
around the mean, rather
than the actual
random variable itself.
You can always do that.
And by doing it, you need to
introduce a little more
terminology, and you get rid of
a lot of mess, because then
the mean doesn't
appear anymore.
So when we start talking about
renewal processes, which we're
going to do here, the
inter-renewal
intervals are positive.
It's important, the the fact
that they're positive, and
that they never go negative.
And because of that, we don't
really want to subtract the
mean off them, because then we
would have a sequence of
random variables that weren't
positive anymore.
So instead of taking away the
mean to avoid a couple of
extra symbols, we're going to
leave the mean in from now on,
so these random variables are
going to converge to some
constant, generally, rather
than converge to 0.
And it doesn't make
any difference.
OK.
So now, the next thing I want to
do is talk about the strong
law for renewal processes.
In other words, I want to talk
about what happens when you
have a renewal counting process
where n of t is the
number of arrivals
up until time t.
And we'd like to see if there's
any kind of law of
large numbers about what happens
to n of t over t as t
gets very large.
And there is such a law, and
that's the kind of thing that
we want to focus on here.
And that's what we're now
starting to talk about.
What was it that made us want
to talk about the strong law
of large numbers instead of the
weak law of large numbers?
It was really the fact that
these sample paths converge.
All these other kinds of
convergence, it's the
distribution function that
converges, it's some
probability of something
that converges.
It's always something gross that
you can look at at every
value of n, and then you can
find the limit of the
distribution function, or find
the limit of the mean, or find
the limit of the relative
frequency, or find the limit
of something else.
When we talk about the strong
law of large numbers, we are
really talking about
these sample paths.
And the fact that we could go
from a convergence theorem
saying that s n to the fourth
over n to the fourth
approached the limit, this was
the convergence theorem.
And from that, we could show
the s sub n over n also
approached the limit, that
really is the key to why the
strong law of large numbers
gets used so much, and
particularly gets used
when we were talking
about renewal processes.
What you will find when we
study we study renewal
processes is that there's
a small part of renewal
processes--
there's a small part of the
theory which really says 80%
of what's important.
And it's almost trivially
simple, and it's built on the
strong law for renewal
processes.
Then there's a bunch of other
things which are not built on
the strong law, they're built
on the weak law or something
else, which are quite
tedious, and quite
difficult, and quite messy.
We go through them because
they get used in a lot of
other places, and they let us
learn about a lot of things
that are very important.
But they still are
more difficult.
And they're more difficult
because we're not talking
about sample paths anymore.
And you're going to see
that at the end
of the lecture today.
You'll see, I think, what is
probably the best illustration
of why the strong law
of large numbers
makes your life simple.
OK.
So we had this fact here.
This theorem is what's going
to generalize this.
Assume that z sub n and greater
than or equal to 1,
this is a sequence of
random variables.
And assume that this sequence of
random variables converges
to some number, alpha,
with probability 1.
In other words, you take sample
paths of this sequence
of a random variables.
And those sample paths, there
two sets of sample paths.
One set of sample paths
converged to alpha, and that
has probability 1.
There's another set of sample
paths, some of them converge
to something else, some of them
converge to nothing, some
of them don't converge at all.
Well, they converge
to nothing.
They don't converge at all.
But that set has probability 0,
so we don't worry about it.
All we're worrying about is this
good set, which is the
set which converges.
And then what the theorem says
is if we have a function f of
x, if it's a real-valued
function of a real variable,
what does that mean?
As an engineer, it means
it's a function.
When you're an engineer and you
talk about functions, you
don't talk about things that
aren't continuous.
You talk about things
that are continuous.
So all that's saying is it gives
us a nice, respectable
function of a variable.
It belongs to the national
academy of real variables that
people like to use.
Then what the theorem says is
that the sequence of random
variables f of z sub n--
OK, we have a real-valued
function of a real variable.
It maps, then, sample values
of z sub n into f of those
sample values.
And because of that, just as
we've done a dozen times
already when you take a
real-valued function of a
random variable, you have
a two-step mapping.
You map from omega into
z n of omega.
And then you map from z n of
omega into f of z n of omega.
That's a simple-minded idea.
OK.
Example one of this, suppose
that f of x is x plus beta.
All this is just a translation,
simple-minded
function, president
of the academy.
And supposes that the sequence
of random variables
converges to alpha.
Then this new set of random
variable u sub n equals z sub
n plus beta.
The translated version converges
to alpha plus beta.
Well, you don't even need
a theorem to see that.
I mean, you can just look at
it and say, of course.
Example two is the one
we've already used.
This one you do have to sweat
over a little bit, but we've
already sweated over it, and
then we're not going to worry
about it anymore.
If f of x is equal to x to the
1/4 for x greater than or
equal to 0, and z n, random
variable, the sequence of
random variables, converges to 0
with probability 1 and these
random variables are
non-negative, then f of z n
converges to f of 0.
That's the one that's a little
less obvious, because if you
look at this function, when x is
very close to 0, but when x
is equal to 0, it's 0,
it goes like this.
When x is 1, you're
up to 1, I guess.
But it really goes up with
an infinite slope here.
It's still continuous at 0 if
you're looking only at the
non-negative values.
That's what we use to
prove the strong
law of large numbers.
None of you complained about
it last time, so you can't
complain about it now.
It's just part of what this
theorem is saying.
This is what the theorem says.
I'm just rewriting it
much more briefly.
Here I'm going to give a "Pf."
For each omega such that limit
of z n of omega equals alpha,
we use the result for a
sequence of numbers that says
the limit of f of z n of
omega, this limit of a set of
sequence of numbers, is equal
to the function at
the limit value.
Let me give you a little diagram
which shows you why
that has to be true.
Suppose you look at
this function f.
This is f of x.
And what we're doing now is
we're looking at a1 here.
a1 is going to be f
of z1 of omega.
a2, I'm just drawing random
numbers here.
a3, a4, a5, a6, a7.
And then I draw f of a1.
So what I'm saying here, in
terms of real numbers, is this
quite trivial thing.
If this function is continuous
at this point, as n gets
large, these numbers get
compressed into that limiting
value there.
And as these numbers get
compressed into that limiting
value, these values up here
get compressed into that
limiting value also.
This is not a proof, but the way
I construct proofs is not
to look for them someplace in
a book, but it's to draw a
picture which shows me what the
idea of the proof is, then
I prove it.
This has an advantage in
research, because if you ever
want to get a result in
research which you can
publish, it has to be
something that you
can't find in a book.
If you do find it in a book
later, then in fact your
result was not new And you're
not supposed to publish
results that aren't new.
So the idea of drawing a picture
and then proving it
from the picture is really
a very valuable
aid in doing research.
And if you draw this picture,
then you can easily construct
a proof of the picture.
But I'm not going
to do it here.
Now, let's go onto renewal
processes.
Each and inter-renewal
interval, x sub i, is positive.
That was what we said
in starting to talk
about renewal processes.
Assuming that the expected
value of x exists, the
expected value of x is then
strictly greater than 0.
You're going to prove that in
the homework this time, too.
When I was trying to get this
lecture ready, I didn't want
to prove anything in detail,
so I had to follow the
strategy of assigning problems,
and the problem set
where you would, in fact, prove
these things, which are
not difficult but
which require a
little bit of thought.
And since the expected value of
x is greater than or equal
to 0, the expected value of s1,
which is expected value of
x, the expected value of x1 plus
x2, which is s2, and so
forth, all of these quantities
are greater than 0 also.
And for each finite n, the
expected value of s sub n over
n is greater than 0 also. so
we're talking about a whole
bunch of positive quantities.
So this strong law of large
numbers is then
going to apply here.
The probability of the sample
paths, s n of omega it over n,
the probability that that sample
path converges to the
mean of x, that's just 1.
Then I use the theorem on
the last page about--
It's this theorem.
When I use f of x equals 1/x
that's continuous at this
positive value.
That's why it's important to
have a positive value for the
expected value of x.
The expected value of x is
equal to 0, 1/x is not
continuous at x equals 0, and
you're in deep trouble.
That's one of the reasons why
you really want to assume
renewal theory and not allow
any inter-renewal intervals
that are equal to 0.
It just louses up the whole
theory, makes things much more
difficult, and you gain
nothing by it.
So we get this statement then,
the probability of sample
points such that the limit of
n over s n of omega is equal
to 1 over x bar.
That limit is equal to 1.
What does that mean?
I look at that and it doesn't
mean anything to me.
I can't see what it means
until I draw a picture.
I'm really into pictures
today.
This was the statement that we
said the probability of this
set of omega such that the limit
of n over s n of omega
is equal to 1 over x
bar is equal to 1.
This is valid whenever you have
a renewal process for
which x bar exists, namely,
the expected value of the
magnitude of x exists.
That was one of the assumptions
we had in here.
And now, this is going
to imply the
strong law renewal processes.
Here's the picture, which lets
us interpret what this means
and let's just go
further with it.
The picture now is you have this
counting process, which
also amounts to a picture of
any set of inter-arrival
instance, x1, x2, x3, x4, and
so forth, and any set of
arrival epochs, s1,
s2, and so forth.
We look at a particular
value of t.
And what I'm interested
in is n of t over t.
I have a theorem about
n over s n of omega.
That's not what I'm
interested in.
I'm interested in
n of t over t.
And this picture shows me what
the relationship is.
So I start out with a
given value of t.
For a given value of t, there's
a well-defined random
variable, which is the number
of arrivals up to and
including time t.
From n of t, I get a
well-defined random variable,
which is the arrival epoch of
the latest arrival less than
or equal to time t.
Now, this is a very funny
kind of random variable.
I mean, we've talked about
random variables which are
functions of other
random variables.
And in a sense, that's
what this.
But it's a little more
awful than that.
Because here we have this
well-defined set of arrival
epochs, and now we're taking a
particular arrival, which is
determined by this t
we're looking at.
So t defines n of t, and n of t
defines s sub n of t, if we
have this entire sample
function.
So this is well-defined.
We will find as we proceed with
this that this random
variable, the time of the
arrival most recently before
t, it's in fact a very, very
strange random variable.
There are strange things
associated with it.
When I look at t minus s sub n
of t, or when I look at the
arrival after t, s sub n of t
plus 1 minus t, those random
variables are peculiar.
And we're going to explain why
they are peculiar and use the
strong law for renewal processes
to look at them in a
kind of a simple way.
But now, the thing we have
here is if we look at the
slope of b of t, the slope of
this line here at each value
of t, this slope is n
of t divided by t.
That's this slope.
This slope here is n of
t over s sub n of t.
Namely, this is the slope up
to the point of the arrival
right before t.
This slope is then going
to decrease as
we move across here.
And at this value here, it's
going to pop up again.
So we have a family of slopes,
which is going to look like--
What's it going to do?
I don't know where it's going to
start out, so I won't even
worry about that.
I'll just start someplace
here.
It's going to be decreasing.
Then there's going
to be an arrival.
At that point, it's going to
increase a little bit.
It's going to be decreasing.
There's another arrival.
So this is s sub n, s sub
n plus 1, and so forth.
So the slope is slowly
decreasing.
And then it changes
discontinuously every time you
have an arrival.
That's the way this behaves.
You start out here, it decreases
slowly, it jumps up,
then it decreases slowly
until the next
arrival, and so forth.
So that's the kind of thing
we're looking at.
But one thing we know is that
n of t over t, that's the
slope in the middle here, is
less than or equal to n of t
over s sub n of t.
Why is that?
Well, n of t is equal to n of
t, but t is greater than or
equal to the time of the
most recent arrival.
So we have n of t over t is less
than or equal to n of t
over s sub n of t.
The other thing that's important
to observe is that
now we want to look at
what happens as t
gets larger and larger.
And what happens to this
ratio, n of t over t?
Well, this ratio n of t over t
is this thing we were looking
at here, which is
kind of a mess.
It jumps up, it goes down a
little bit, jumps up, goes
down a little bit, jumps up.
But the set of values that
it goes through--
the set of values that this goes
through, namely, the set
right before each
of these jumps--
is the same set of values
as n over s sub n.
As I look through this sequence,
I look at this n of
t over s sub n of t.
That's this point here, and then
it's this point there.
Anyway, n of t over s sub n of t
is going to stay constant as
t goes from here
over to there.
That's the way I've
drawn the picture.
I start out with any t in
this interval here.
This slope keeps changing as
t goes from there to there.
This slope does not change.
This is determined just by which
particular integer value
of n we're talking about.
So n of t over s sub n of t
jumps at each value of n.
So this now becomes just the
sequence of numbers.
And that sequence of numbers
is the sequence n
divided by s sub b.
Why is that important?
That's the thing we have
some control over.
That's what appears up here.
So we know how to
deal with that.
That's what this result about
convergence added to this
result about functions of
converging functions tells us.
So redrawing the same figure,
we've observed that n of t
over t is less than or equal to
n of t over s sub n of t.
It goes through the same set of
values as n over s sub n,
and therefore the limit as t
goes to infinity of n over t
over s sub n of t is the same
as the limit as n goes to
infinity of n over s sub n.
And that limit, with
probability
1, is 1 over x bar.
That's the thing that this
theorem, we just
"pfed" said to us.
There's a bit of a pf in here
too, because you really ought
to show that as t goes
to infinity, n
of t goes to infinity.
And that's not hard to do.
It's done in the notes.
You need to do it.
You can almost see intuitively
that it has to happen.
And in fact, it does
have to happen.
OK.
So this, in fact, is a limit.
It does exist.
Now, we go on the other y, and
we look at n of t over t,
which is now greater than or
equal to n of t over s sub n
of t plus 1.
s sub b of t plus 1 is the
arrival epoch which is just
larger than t.
Now, n of t over s sub n of t
plus 1 goes through the same
set of values as n over
s sub n plus 1.
Namely, each time n increases,
this goes up by 1.
So the limit as t goes to
infinity of n of t over s sub
n of t plus 1 is the same as
the limit as n goes to
infinity of n over the epoch
right after n of t.
This you can rewrite as n plus
1 over s sub n plus 1 times n
over n plus 1.
Why do I want to rewrite
it this way?
Because this quantity
I have a handle on.
This is the same as the limit
of n over s sub n.
I know what that limit is.
This quantity, I have an even
better handle on, because this
n over n plus 1 just moves--
it's something that
starts out low.
And as n gets bigger, it just
moves up towards 1.
And therefore, when you look at
this limit, this has to be
1 over x bar also.
Since n of t over t is between
these two quantities, they
both have the same limit.
The limit of n of t over t is
equal to 1 over the expected
value of x.
STUDENT: Professor Gallager?
ROBERT GALLAGER: Yeah?
STUDENT: Excuse me if this is
a dumb question, but in the
previous slide it said the limit
as t goes to infinity of
the accounting process n of
t, would equal infinity.
We've also been talking a lot
over the last week about the
defectiveness and
non-defectiveness of these
counting processes.
So we can still find an n that's
sufficiently high, such
that the probability of n of t
being greater than that n is
0, so it's not defective.
But I don't know.
How do you--
ROBERT GALLAGER: n of t is
either a random variable or a
defective random variable
of each value of t.
And what I'm claiming
here, which is not--
This is something you
have to prove.
But what I would like to show is
that for each value of t, n
of t is not defective.
In other words, these
arrivals have to
come sometime or other.
OK.
Well, let's backtrack from
that a little bit.
For n of t to be defective, I
would have to have an infinite
number of arrivals come in
in some finite time.
You did a problem in the
homework where that could
happen, because the x sub i's
you were looking at were not
identically distributed, so
that as t increased, the
number of arrivals you had were
increasing very, very rapidly.
Here, that can't happen.
And the reason it can't happen
is because we've started out
with a renewal process where
by definition the
inter-arrival intervals all have
the same distribution.
So the rate of arrivals,
in a sense, is
staying constant forever.
Now, that's not a proof.
If you look at the notes, the
notes have a proof of this.
After you go through the proof,
you say, that's a
little bit tedious.
But you either have to go
through the tedious proof to
see what is after you go through
it is obvious, or you
have to say it's obvious,
which is a
subject to some question.
So yes, it was not a
stupid question.
It was a very good question.
And in fact, you do have
to trace that out.
And that's involved here in
this in what we've done.
I want to talk a little bit
about the central limit
theorem for renewals.
The notes don't prove
the central
limit theorem for renewals.
I'm not going to
prove it here.
All I'm going to do is give you
an argument why you can
see that it sort of has to be
true, if you don't look at any
of the weird special cases you
might want to look at.
So there is a reference given
in the text for where
you can find it.
I mean, I like to give proofs
of very important things.
I didn't give a proof of this
because the amount of work to
prove it was far greater than
the importance of the result,
which means it's a very, very
tricky and very difficult
thing to prove, even when you're
only talking about
things like Bernoulli.
OK.
But here's the picture.
And the picture, I think, will
make it sort of clear
what's going on.
We're talking now about an
underlying random variable x.
We assume it has a second
moment, which we need to make
the central limit
theorem true.
The probability that s sub n is
less than or equal to t for
n very large and for the
difference between t--
Let's look at the
whole statement.
What it's saying is if you look
at values of t which are
equal to the mean for s sub n,
which is n x bar, plus some
quantity alpha times sigma times
the square root of n,
then as n gets large and t gets
correspondingly large,
this probability is
approximately equal to the
normal distribution function.
In other words, what that's
saying is as I'm looking at
the random variable, s sub n,
and taking n very, very large.
The expected value of s sub n is
equal to n times x bar, so
I'm moving way out where this
number is very, very large.
As n gets larger and larger, n
increases and x bar increases,
and they increase on a
slope 1 over x bar.
So this is n, this
is n over x bar.
The slope is n over n over x
bar, which is this slope here.
Now, when you look at this
picture, what it sort of
involves is you can choose
any n you want.
We will assume the
x bar is fixed.
You can choose any t
that you want to.
Let's first hold b fixed and
look at a third dimension now,
where for this particular
value of n, I
want to look at the--
And instead of looking at the
distribution function, let me
look at a probability density,
which makes the argument
easier to see.
As I look at this for a
particular value of n, what
I'm going to get is b x bar.
This will be the probability
density of s sub n of x.
And that's going to look like,
when n is large enough, it's
going to look like a Gaussian
probability density.
And the mean of that Gaussian
probability density will be
mean n x bar.
And the variance of this
probability density, now, is
going to be the square root
of n times sigma.
What else do I need?
I guess that's it.
This is the standard
deviation.
OK.
So you can visualize
what happens, now.
As you start letting n get
bigger and bigger, you have
this Gaussian density
for each value of n.
Think of drawing this again for
some larger value of n.
The mean will shift out
corresponding to a linear
increase in n.
The standard deviation will
shift out, but only according
to the square root of n.
So what's happening is the same
thing that always happens
in the central limit theorem, is
that as n gets large, this
density here is moving out with
n, and it's getting wider
with the square root of n.
So it's getting wider much
more slowly than
it's getting bigger.
Than It's getting wider
much more slowly
than it's moving out.
So if I try to look at what
happens, what's the
probability that n of t is
greater than or equal to n?
I now want to look at the same
curve here, but instead of
looking at it here for a fixed
value of n, I want to look at
the probability density out here
at some fixed value of t.
So what's going to happen?
The probability density here is
going to be the probability
density that we we're talking
about here, but for
this value up here.
The probability density here is
going to correspond to the
probability density here, and
so forth as we move down.
So what's happening to this
probability density is that as
we move up, the standard
deviation is getting
a little bit wider.
As we move down, standard
deviation is getting a little
bit smaller.
And as n gets bigger and bigger,
this shouldn't make
any difference.
So therefore, if you buy for the
moment the fact that this
doesn't make any difference,
you have a Gaussian density
going this way, you
have a Gaussian
density centered here.
Up here you have a Gaussian
density centered
here at this point.
And all those Gaussian densities
are the same, which
means you have a Gaussian
density going this way, which
is centered here.
Here's the upper tail of
that Gaussian density.
Here's the lower tail of
Now, to put that analytically,
it's saying that the
probability that n of t is
greater than or equal to n,
that's the same as the
probability that s sub n is
less than or equal to t.
So that is the distribution
function of s sub n less than
or equal to t.
When we go from n to t, what we
find is that n is equal to
t over x bar--
that's the mean we have here--
minus alpha times sigma
times the square
root of n over x bar.
In other words, what
is happening is
the following thing.
We have a density going this
way, which has variance, which
has standard deviation
proportional to the
square root of n.
When we look at that same
density going this way,
ignoring the fact that this
distance here that we're
looking at is very small, this
density here is going to be
compressed by this slope here.
In other words, what we have is
the probability that n of t
greater than or equal to
n is approximately
equal to phi of alpha.
n is equal to t over x bar minus
this alpha here times
sigma times the square
root of n over x bar.
Nasty equation, because
we have an n on both
sides of the equation.
So we will try to solve
this equation.
And this is approximately equal
to t over x bar minus
alpha times sigma times the
square root of n over x bar
times the square root of x.
Why is that true?
Because it's approximately equal
to the square root--
Well, it is equal to the square
root of t over x bar,
which is this quantity here.
And since this quantity here
is small relative to this
quantity here, when you solve
this equation for t, you're
going to ignore this term
and just get this small
correction term here.
That's exactly the same thing
that I said when I was looking
at this graphically, when I was
saying that if you look at
the density at larger values
than n, you get a standard
deviation which is larger.
When you look at a smaller
value of n, you get is a
standard deviation
which is smaller.
Which means that when you look
at it along here, you're going
to get what looks like a
Gaussian density, except the
standard deviation is a little
expanded up there and little
shrunk down here.
But that doesn't make any
difference as n gets very
large, because that shrinking
factor is proportional to the
square root of n
rather than n.
Now beyond that, you just
have to look at this
and live with it.
Or else you have to look up a
proof of it, which I don't
particularly recommend.
So this is the central limit
theorem for renewal processes.
n of t tends to Gaussian with
a mean t over x bar and a
standard deviation sigma times
square root of t over x bar
times 1 over square root of x.
And now you sort of understand
why that is, I hope.
OK.
Next thing I want to
go to is the time
average residual life.
You were probably somewhat
bothered when you saw with
Poisson processes that if you
arrived to wait for a bus, the
expected time between buses
turned out to be twice the
expected time from one
bus to the next.
Namely, whenever you arrive to
look for a bus, the time until
the next bus was an exponential
random variable.
The time back to the last bus,
if you're far enough in, was
an exponential random
variable.
The sum of two, the expected
value from the time before
until the time later, was
twice what it should be.
And we went through some kind
of song and dance saying
that's because you come in at a
given point and you're more
likely to come in during one of
these longer inter-arrival
periods than you are to
come in during a short
inter-arrival.
And it has to be a song and a
dance, and it didn't really
explain anything very well,
because we were locked into
the exponential density.
Now we have an advantage.
We can explain things like that,
because we can look at
any old distribution we want to
look at, and that will let
us see what this thing which
is called the paradox of
residual life really
amounts to.
It's what tells us why we
sometimes have to wait a very
much longer time than we think
we should if we understand
some particular kind
of process.
So here's where we're
going to start.
What happened?
I lost a slide.
Ah.
There we are.
Residual life, y of t, of a
renewal process at times t, is
the remaining time until
the next renewal.
Namely, we have this counting
process for any
given renewal process.
We have this random variable,
which is the time of the first
arrival after t, which is
s sub n of t plus 1.
And that difference
is the duration
until the next arrival.
Starting at time t, there's a
random variable, which is the
time from t until the next
arrival after t.
That is specifically the arrival
epoch of the arrival
after time t, which is s sub n
of t plus 1 minus the number
of arrivals that have occurred
up until time t.
You take any sample path of this
renewal process, and y of
t will have some value
in that sample path.
As I say here, this is how long
you have to wait for a
bus if the bus arrivals were
renewal processes.
STUDENT: Should it also be
s n t, where there is
minus sign on that?
ROBERT GALLAGER: No, because
just by definition, a residual
life, the residual life starting
at time t is the time
for the next arrival.
There's also something called
age that we'll talk about
later, which is how long is it
back to the last arrival.
In other words, that age is
the age of the particular
inter-arrival interval that
you happen to be in.
Yes?
STUDENT: It should be s sub n of
t plus 1 minus t instead of
minus N, because it's
the time from t to--
ROBERT GALLAGER: Yes,
I agree with you.
There's something wrong there.
I'm sorry.
That I should be s sub n
of t plus 1 minus t.
Good.
That's what happens
when you make up
slides too late at night.
And as I said, we'll talk about
something called age,
which is a of t is equal to
t minus s sub n of t.
So this is a random variable
defined at every value of t.
What we'd like to look at now is
what does that look like as
a sample function as
a sample path.
The residual life is
a function of t--
Nicest way to view residual
life is that it's a reward
function on a renewal process.
A renewal process just
consists of these--
Well, you can look
at in three ways.
It's a sequence of inter-arrival
times, all
identically distributed.
It's the sequence of
arrival epochs.
Or it's this unaccountably
infinite number of random
variables, n of t.
Given that process, you can
define whatever kind of reward
you want to, which is the same
kind of reward we were talking
about with Markov chains, where
you just define some
kind of reward that you achieve
at each value of t.
But that reward--
we'll talk about reward
on renewal processes--
is restricted to be a reward
which is a function only of
the particular inter-arrival
interval that you
happen to be in.
Now, I don't want to talk about
that too much right now,
because it is easier to
understand residual life than
it is to understand the general
idea of these renewal
reward functions.
So we'll just talk about
residual life to start with,
and then get back to the
more general thing.
We would like, sometimes, to
look at the time-average value
of residual life, which is you
take the residual life at time
tau, you integrate it at the
time t, and then you
divide by time t.
This is the time average
residual life from
0 up to time t.
We will now ask the question,
does this have a limit as t
goes to infinity?
And we will see that,
in fact, it does.
So let's draw a picture.
Here is a picture of some
arbitrary renewal process.
I've given the inter-arrival
times, x1, x2, so forth, the
arrival epochs, s1, s2,
so forth, and n of t.
Now, let's ask, for this
particular sample function
what is the residual life?
Namely, at each value of t,
what's the time until the next
arrival occurs?
Well, this is a perfectly
specific function of this
individual sample
function here.
This is a sample function, now
in the interval from 0 to s1,
the time until the
next arrival.
It starts out as x1,
drops down to 0.
Now, don't ask the question,
what is my residual life if I
don't know what the rest of
the sample function is?
That's not the question
we're asking here.
The question we're asking is
somebody gives you a picture
of this entire sample path, and
you want to find out, for
that particular picture, what is
the residual life at every
value of t.
And for a value of t very close
to 0, the residual life
is the time up to s1.
So it's decaying linearly
down to 0 at s1.
At s1, it jumps up immediately
to x2, which is the time from
any time after s1 to s2.
I have a little circle
down there.
And from x2, it decays
down to 0.
So we have a whole bunch
here of triangles.
So for any sample function, we
have this sample function of
residual life, which is, in
fact, just decaying triangles.
It's nothing more than that.
For every t in here, the amount
of time until the next
arrival is simply s2 minus t,
which is that value there.
This decay is with slope minus
1, so there's nothing to
finding out what this
is if you know this.
This is a very simple
function of that.
So a residual-life sample
function is a sequence of
isosceles triangles,
one starting at
each arrival epoch.
The time average for a given
sample function is, how do I
find the time average starting
from 0 going up to
some large value t?
Well, I simply integrate these
isosceles triangles.
And I can integrate these, and
you can integrate these, and
anybody who's had a high school
education can integrate
these, because it's just the
sum of the areas of all of
these triangles.
So this area here is 1 over 2
times x sub i squared, then we
divide by t.
So it's 1 over t times
this integral.
This integral here is the area
of the first triangle plus the
area of the second triangle plus
1/3 plus 1/4, plus this
little runt thing at the end,
which is, if I pick t in here,
this little runt thing is
going to be that little
trapezoid, which we could figure
out if we wanted to,
but we don't want to.
The main thing is we get this
sum of squares here, there
that's easy enough
to deal with.
So this is what we found here.
It is easier to bound this
quantity, instead of having
that little runt at the end, to
drop the runt to this side
and to extend the runt
on this side to the
entire isosceles triangles.
So this time average residual
life at the time t is between
this and this.
The limit of this as t goes
to infinity is what?
Well, it's just a limit
of a sequence
of IID random variables.
No, excuse me.
We are dealing here with
sample function.
So what we have is a limit
as t goes to infinity.
And I want to rewrite this
here as x sub n squared
divided by n of t times
n has to t over 2t.
I want to separate it, and
just divide it and
multiply by n of t.
I want to look at this term.
What happens to this term
as t gets large?
Well, as t gets large,
n of t gets large.
This quantity here just goes
through the same set of values
as the sum up to some finite
limit divided by that limit
goes through.
So the limit of this quantity
here is just the expected
value of x squared.
What is this quantity here?
Well, this is what the renewal
theorem deals with.
This limit here is 1 over 2
times the expected value of x.
That's what we showed before.
This goes to a limit, this goes
to a limit, the whole
thing goes to a limit.
And it goes to limit
with probability 1
for all sample functions.
So this time average residual
life has the expected value of
x squared divided by 2 times
the expected value of x.
Now if you look at this, you'll
see that what we've
done is something which is very
simple, because of the
fact we have renewal theory
at this point.
If we had to look at the
probabilities of where all of
these arrival epochs occur,
and then deal with all of
those random variables, and
go through some enormously
complex calculation to find
the expected value of this
residual life at the time
t, it would be an
incredibly hard problem.
But looking at it in terms of
sample paths for random
variables, it's an incredibly
simple problem.
Want to look at one example
here, because when we look at
this, well, first thing
is just a couple of
examples to work out.
The time average residual life
has expected value of x
squared over 2 times the
expected value of x.
If x is almost deterministic,
then the expected value of x
squared is just a square of
the expected value of x.
So we wind up with the expected
value of x over 2,
which is sort of what you would
expect if you look from
time 0 to time infinity, and
these arrivals come along
regularly, then the expected
time you have to wait for the
next arrival varies
from 0 up to x.
And the average of it is x/2.
So no problem there.
If x is exponential, we've
already found out that the
expected time we have to wait
until the next arrival is the
expected value of x, because
these arrivals are memoryless.
So I start looking at this
Poisson process at a given
value of t, and the time until
the next arrival is
exponential, and it's the same
as the expected time from one
arrival to the next arrival.
So we have that quantity
there, which
looks a little strange.
This one, this is a very
peculiar random variable.
But this really explains what's
going on with this kind
of paradoxical thing, which we
found with a Poisson process,
where if you arrive to wait for
a bus, you're waiting time
is not any less because of the
fact that you've just arrived
between two arrivals, and it
ought to be the same distance
back to the last one at a
distance of first one.
That was always a little
surprising.
This, I think, explains
what's going on
better than most things.
Look at a binary random
variable, x, where the
probability that x is equal to
epsilon is 1 minus epsilon,
and the probability that
x is equal to 1
over epsilon is epsilon.
And think of epsilon as
being very large.
So what happens?
You got a whole bunch of little,
tiny inter-renewal
intervals, which are
epsilon apart.
And then with very small
probability, you get an
enormous one.
And you wait for 1
over epsilon for
that one to be finished.
Then you've got a bunch of
little ones which are all
epsilon apart.
Then you get an enormous one,
which is 1 over epsilon long.
And now you can see perfectly
well that if you arrive to
wait for a bus and the buses are
distributed this way, this
is sort of what happens when you
have a bus system which is
perfectly regular but
subject to failures.
Whenever you have a failure,
you have an
incredibly long wait.
Otherwise, you have
very small waits.
So what happens here?
The duration of this whole
interval here of these little,
tiny inter-arrival times, the
distance between failure in a
sense, is 1 minus epsilon,
as it turns out.
It's very close to 1.
This distance here is
1 over epsilon.
And this quantity here,
if you work it out--
Let's see.
What is it?
We take this distribution here,
we look for the expected
value of x squared.
Let's see.
1 over epsilon squared times
epsilon, which is 1 over
epsilon plus 1 minus epsilon
times something.
So the expected time that you
have to wait if you arrive
somewhere along here is
1 over 2 epsilon.
If epsilon is very small, you
have a very, very long waiting
time because of these very long
distributions in here.
You normally don't tend to
arrive in any of these periods
or any of these periods.
But however you want to
interpret it, this theorem
about renewals tells you
precisely that the time
average residual life
is, in fact, this
quantity 1 over 2 epsilon.
That's this paradox
of residual life.
Your residual life is much
larger than it looks like it
ought to be, because it's not
by any means the same as the
expected interval between
successive arrivals, which in
this case is very small.
OK I think I'll stop there.
And we will talk more about
this next time.